‏sk
[Silence]
الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله حي على
الصلاه حي على الفلاح قد قامت الصلاه قد
قامت الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله
الله
[Silence]
الحد استقيم واستووا ترس
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط راط المستقيم صراط
الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين يسبح لله ما في السماوات وما في
الارض الملك القدوس العزيز
الحكيم هو الذي بعث في
الامميين رسولا منهم يتلوا عليهم اياته
ويزكيهم
ويعلمهم الكتاب والحكمه وان كانوا من قبل
لفي ضلال
مبين واخرين منهم لما يلحقوا بهم وهو
العزيز الحكيم
ذلك فضل الله يؤتيه من
يشاء والله ذو الفضل
العظيم مثل الذين حملوا التوراه ثم لم
يحملوها كمثل الحمار يحمل
اسفارا بئس مثل القوم الذين كذبوا بايات
الله والله لا يهدي القوم الظالمين
قل يا ايها الذين هادوا ان زعمتم انكم
اولياء لله من دون الناس
فتمنوا الموت ان كنتم
صادقين ولا
يتمنونه ابدا بما قدمت ايديهم والله عليم
بالظالمين قل ان الموتى الذي تفرون منه
فانه ملاقيكم ثم تردون الى عالم الغيب
والشهاده
فينبئكم بما كنتم
تعملون يا ايها الذين امنوا اذا نودي
للصلاه من يوم الجمعه فاسعوا الى ذكر الله
وذروا
البيع ذلكم خير لكم ان كنتم
تعلمون فاذا قضيت الصلاه
فانتشروا في الارض وابتغوا من فضل الله
واذكروا الله كثيرا لعلكم
تفلحون واذا راوا تجاره او لهوا انفضوا
اليها وتركوك
قائما
قل ما عند الله خير من اللهو ومن
التجاره والله خير
الرازقين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضال
ين
امين اذا
جاءك
المنافقون قالوا نشهد انك لرسول الله
والله يعلم انك لرسوله والله يشهد ان
المنافقين
لكاذبون اتخذوا ايمانهم جن سنه فصدوا عن
سبيل الله انهم
ساء ما كانوا
يعملون ذلك بانهم امنوا ثم كفروا فطبع على
قلوبهم فهم لا
يفقهون واذا رايتهم تعجبك اجسامهم وان
يقولوا تسمع لقولهم كانهم خشب
مسنده يحسبون كل صيحه عليهم هم العدو
فاحذرهم قاتلهم الله انا
يؤفكون واذا واذا قيل لهم تعالوا يستغفر
لكم رسول الله لووا رؤوسهم ورايتهم يصدون
وهم
مستكبرون
سواء عليهم استغفرت لهم ام لم تستغفر لهم
لن يغفر الله لهم ان الله لا يهدي القوم
الفاسقين هم الذين يقولون لا تنفقوا على
من عند رسول الله حتى
ينفضوا ولله
خزائن السماوات والارض
ولكن المنافقين لا يفقهون
يقولون لئن رجعنا الى المدينه ليخرجن
الاعز منها
الاذل ولله العزه ولرسوله وللمؤمنين ولكن
المنافقين لا
يعلمون يا ايها الذين امنوا لا تلهكم
اموالكم ولا اولادكم عن ذكر
الله ومن يفعل ذلك
فاولئك هم
الخاسرون
وانفقوا مما
رزقناكم من قبل ان ياتي احدكم الموت
فيقول فيقول رب لولا اخرتني الى اجل قريب
فاصدق واكن من
الصالحين ولن يؤخر الله نفسا اذا جاء
اجلها والله خبير بما
تعملون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر
اكبر بسم الله
الرحمن
[Silence]
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
‏st
‏after ‏share with you the backgr
because i want please understand not
tring to tell st i need to expl to you
so i make that requ properly and you
could help me as you know that we do not
own the parking lot next to us that's
church paring l right church space
not they have
graciously alled us to paring space and
they not put any restri on us until now
‏kind
the
par and not
watching
car
ulle
‏think block
own so all of this come to now and i
request you to pleas not st
par it happ so i need you most of the
time are the here
right
‏take do not do this and feel are offend
at let us and go talk so to go work on
this thing to make we continue using the
paring spot paring space as we have been
for
multi things
anno
‏ly
own own
s our own not need value this life so
the are not break own
isic are
trans
10 care and sl
even pleas do that requ
and
can
‏make
[Silence]
not
‏take that not
that
lot
out so just don't know how exp you and
sister
this to
take and
something
let let
me as be
‏which and make as
as
not and
some so pleas
make
[Silence]
كم
الصلاه القيام استقيم
واست الله اكبر
اك بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا
الضالين
امين يسبح لله ما في السماوات والارض له
الملك وله الحمد وهو على كل شيء قدير
هو الذي خلقكم
فمنكم كافر ومنكم مؤمن والله بما تعملون
بصير خلق السماوات والارض بالحق وصوركم
فاحسن صوركم واليه
المصير يعلم ما في السماوات والارض ويعلم
ما تسرون وما
تعلنون والله عليم بذات
الصدور الم ياتكم نبا الذين كفروا من قبل
فذاقوا وبال امرهم ولهم عذاب
اليم ذلك بانه كانت تاتيهم رسلهم بالبينات
فقالوا ابشر
يهدوننا فكفروا وتولوا واستغنى الله والله
غني
حميد زعم الذين كفروا ان لن يبعثوا قل بلى
وربي
لتبعثن ثم
لتنبؤن بما عملتم وذلك على الله
يسير فامنوا بالله ورسوله والنور الذي
انزلنا والله بما تعملون
خبير يوم يجمعكم ليوم الجمع ذلك يوم
التغابن ومن يؤمن بالله ويعمل صالحا يكفر
عنه سيئاته ويدخله
جنات ويدخله جنات تجري من تحتها الانهار
خالدين فيها ابدا ذلك الفوز
العظيم والذين كفروا وكذبوا باياتنا
اولئك اصحاب النار خالدين فيها وبئس
المصير ما اصاب من مصيبه الا باذن
الله ومن يؤمن بالله يهد قلبه والله بكل
شيء
عليم واطيعوا الله واطيعوا
رسول
فان توليتم فانما على رسولنا البلاغ
المبين الله لا اله الا هو وعلى الله
فليتوكل
المؤمنون يا ايها الذين امنوا ان من
ازواجكم واولادكم عدوا لكم
فاحذروهم وان ان تعفوا وتصفحوا وتغفروا
فان الله غفور
رحيم انما اموالكم واولادكم فتنه والله
عنده اجر
عظيم فاتقوا الله ما استطعتم واسمعوا
واطيعوا
وانفقوا خيرا
لانفسكم و من يوق شح نفسه
فاولئك هم
المفلحون ان تقرضوا الله قرضا حسنا يضاعفه
لكم ويغفر لكم والله شكور
حليم عالم الغيب والشهاده العزيز
الحكيم الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين يا ايها النبي اذا طلقتم
النساء فط لوهن لعدتهن واحصوا العده
واتقوا الله
ربكم لا تخرجوهن من بيوتهن ولا يخرجن الا
ان ياتين بفاحشه
مبينه وتلك حدود
الله ومن يتعد حدود الله فقد ظلم
نفسه لا تدري لعل الله يحدث بعد ذلك
امرا فاذا بلغن اجلهن فامسكوهن
بمعروف او
فارقوهن
بمعروف واشهدوا ذوي عدل
منكم واقيموا الشهاده
لله ذلكم يوعظ به من كان يؤمن بالله
واليوم
الاخر ومن يتق الله يجعل له مخرجا ويرزقه
من حيث لا
يحتسب ومن يتوكل على الله فهو
حسبه ان الله بالغ امره قد جعل الله لكل
شيء قدرا
ولاء يئسن من المحيض من
نسائكم ان ارتبتم
فعدتهن ثلاثه اشهر
واللائي لم يحطن واولات الاحمال اجلهن ان
يضعن
حملهن ومن يتق الله يجعل له من امره
يسرا ذلك امر الله انزله
اليكم ومن يتق الله يكفر عنه سيئاته ويعظم
له
اجرا اسكنوهن من حيث
سكنتم من
وجدكم ولا
تضاروهن
لتضيقوا
عليهن وان كن اولات حمل فانفقوا عليهن حتى
يضعن
حملهن فان ارض ع لكم
فاتوهن
اجورهن واتمروا بينكم
بمعروف وان تعاسرتم فسترضع له
اخرى لينفق ذو سعه من
سعته ومن قدر عليه رزقه فلينفق مما اتاه
الله لا يكلف الله نفسا الا ما
اتاها سيجعل الله بعد عسر
يسرا وكاي من قريه عتت عن امر ربها ورسله
فحاسبناها
حسابا شديدا
وعذبها عذابا
نكرا فذاقت وبال امرها وكان عاقبه امرها
خسرا
اعد الله لهم عذابا
شديدا فاتقوا الله يا اولي الالباب الذين
امنوا قد انزل الله اليكم
ذكرا رسولا يتلوا عليكم ايات الله مبينات
ليخرج الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات من
الظلمات الى
النور
ومن يؤمن بالله ويعمل صالحا يكفر عنه
سيئاته ويدخله
جنات تجري من تحتها الانهار خالدين فيها
ابدا ومن يؤمن بالله ويعمل صالحا يدخله
ابدا قد احسن الله له
رزقا الله الذي خلق سبع
سماوات ومن الارض
مثلهن يتنزل الامر
بينهن لتعلموا ان الله على كل شيء
قدير وان الله قد احاط بكل شيء
علما الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
الله اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا
الضالين
امين يا ايها النبي لم تحرم ما احل الله
لك تبتغي مرضاه ازواجك والله غفور
رحيم قد فرض الله لكم تحله ايمانكم والله
مولاكم وهو العليم
الحكيم واذ اسر النبي الى بعض ازواجه
حديثا فلما نبات به واظهره الله عليه عرف
بعضه واعرض عن
بعض فلما نب ها به قالت من انباك
هذا قال نباني العليم
الخبير ان تتوبا الى الله فقد صغت
قلوبكما وان تظاهرا عليه فان الله هو
مولاه وجبريل وصالح
المؤمنين
والملا
ئكه بعد ذلك
ظهير عسى ربه ان
طلقكن ان يبدله ازواجا خيرا
منكن
مسلمات
مؤمنات
قانتات
تائبات
عابدات
سا ئ حات
ثيبات
وابكارا يا ايها الذين امنوا قوا انفسكم
واهليكم نارا وقودها الناس
والحجاره عليها
ملائكه غلاظ شداد لا يعصون الله ما امرهم
ويفعلون ما
يؤمرون
يا ايها الذين كفروا لا تعتذروا
اليوم انما تجزون ما كنتم
تعملون يا ايها الذين امنوا توبوا الى
الله توبه
نصوحا عسى ربكم ان يكفر عنكم سيئاتكم
ويدخلكم
جنات تجري من تحتها
الانهار يوم لا يخزي الله النبي والذين
امنوا معه نورهم يسعى بين ايديهم
وبايمانهم
يقولون يقولون ربنا اتمم لنا نورنا واغفر
لنا انك على كل شيء قدير
يا ايها النبي جاهد الكفار والمنافقين
واغلظ عليهم وماواهم جهنم وبئس
المصير ضرب الله مثلا للذين كفروا امراه
نوح وامراه لوط كانتا تحت عبدين من عبادنا
صالحين فخانتاهما
فخانتاهما فلم يغنيا عنهما من الله شيئا
وقيل ادخل النار مع
الداخلين وضرب الله مثلا للذين امنوا
امراه فرعون اذ قالت رب ابن لي عندك بيتا
في الجنه
ونجني ونجني من فرعون وعمله ونجني من
القوم
الظالمين ومريم ابنه عمران التي احصنت
فرجها فنفخنا فيه من روحنا وصدقت بكلمات
ربها
وكتبه وصدقت بكلمات ربها وكتبه وكانت من
القانتين
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
تبارك الذي بيده الملك وهو على كل شيء
قدير الذي خلق الموت والحياه ليبلوكم ايكم
احسن عملا وهو العزيز
الغفور الذي خلق سبع سماوات ان طباقا ما
ترى في خلق الرحمن من
تفاوت فارجع البصر هل ترى من
فطور ثم ارجع البصر كرتين ينقلب اليك
البصر
خاسئا وهو
حسير ولقد زينا
السماء الدنيا بمصابيح
وجعلناها رجوما للشياطين
واعتدنا لهم عذابا
السعير وللذين كفروا بربهم عذاب جهنم وبئس
المصير اذا القوا فيها سمعوا لها شهيقا
وهي
تفور تكاد تميز من
الغيظ كلما القي فيها فوج سالهم خزنتها
الم ياتكم
نذير قالوا بلى قد
جاءنا نذير فكذبنا وقلنا ما نزل الله من
شيء ان انتم الا في
ضلال ان انتم الا في ضلال
كبير وقالوا لو كنا نسمع او نعقل ما كنا
في اصحاب
السعير فاعترفوا
بذنبهم فسحقا لاصحاب
السعير ان الذين يخشون ربهم بالغيب لهم
مغفره واجر
كبير واسروا قولكم او اجهروا به انه عليم
بذات
الصدور الا يعلم من خلق و هو اللطيف
الخبير هو الذي جعل لكم الارض ذلولا
فامشوا في مناكبها وكلوا من رزقه واليه
النشور
اامنتم من في
السماء ان يخسف بكم الارض فاذا هي
تمور ام
امنتم من في السماء
ان يرسل عليكم حاصبا
فستعلمون كيف
نذير ولقد كذب الذين من قبلهم فكيف كان
نكير اولم يروا الى الطير فوقهم
صافات
ويقبض ما يمسكهن الا
الرحمن انه بكل شيء
بصير امن هذا الذي هو جند لكم
ينصركم من دون
الرحمن ان الكافرون الا في
غرور امن هذا الذي يرزقكم ان امسك رزقه بل
لجوا في عتو
ونفور افمن يمشي مكبا على وجهه اهدى امن
يمشي سويا على صراط
مستقيم قل هو الذي انشاكم وجعل لكم السمع
والابصار والافئده قليلا ما
تشكرون قل هو الذي دراكم في الارض واليه
تحشرون ويقولون متى هذا الوعد ان كنتم
صادقين قل انما العلم عند الله وانما انا
نذير
مبين فلما راوه
زلفه
سيئت وجوه الذين كفروا وقيل هذا الذي كنتم
به
تدعون قل ارايتم ان اهلك الله ومن معي او
رحمنا فمن يجير الكافرين من عذاب
اليم قل هو الرحمن امنا به وعليه توكلنا
فستعلمون من هو في
ضلال
مبين قل ارايتم ان اصبح
ماؤكم غورا فمن
ياتيكم
بماء
معين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم والصلاه والسلام
على رسول الله وعلى اله وصحبه ون ولا ومن
تبعه باحسان اليوم الدين اما
بعد سير عليه الصلاه
وسلام رسول الله صل علسلم
‏pr
[Silence]
over عليه
الهلامه عليه
[Silence]
عن
عالى
الله
اب
[Silence]
ليهه
عليه الصلاه والسلام نذ
بالذ
بالهال نذ بالله you
are
[Silence]
لام uncle of his which think called
him so you know b unle and then in the
nar
علي
[Silence]
الحد
مص
فمن حج
بيتم فلا جنا
عليه
الله اللهه
[Silence]
ح
يا
معشه
مع يا بنشم ب قش يا بن
سعد
[Silence]
‏some
‏ust
tri
[Silence]
معول الله علسلم
عليه
[Silence]
‏said
عليه ابو
لهب عليك يا
يعني الله
سبحان المسد تبت يدا ابي لهب وتب ما اغن
عنه ماله وما كسب الله سبحان
وتى
[Silence]
‏i
‏person
عليهه
اللهانه
[Silence]
الح اله
الله ‏you know finish with this tell a
lot of people come
to saying is
eas
all
par
things
[Silence]
‏life
‏those two placing exem
fam from the aven that he knows and we
do not know and he gives them peace in
their hearts and tranquility from his
own sources
of angs arm not
[Silence]
‏of
kind
ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي الاخره حسنه
وقنا عذاب النار وقنا عذاب القبر وقنا
عذاب جهنم ربنا تقبل منا انك السميع
العليم وتب عل تواب الرحيم وصلى الله على
محمد وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين امين اللهم
امين اللهم امين اللهم
[Silence]
امين استقيم واعتدل ستو سو الصف سدوا
الخلل الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضال
ين
امين
نون والقلم وما
يسطرون ما انت بنعمه ربك
بمجنون وان لك لاجرا غير
ممنون وانك لعلى خلق
عظيم
فستبصر
ويبصرون بايكم
المفتون ان ربك هو اعلم بمن ضل عن سبيله
وهو اعلم بالمهتدين
فلا تطع
المكذبين ودوا لو تدهن
فيدهنون ولا تطع كل حلاف مهين
هماز مش
الشاء
بنميم من ناع للخير معتد
اثيم
عتل بعد ذلك
زنيم ان كان ذا مال
وبنين اذا تتلى عليه اياتنا قال اساطير
الاولين
سنسمه على
الخرطوم انا بلوناهم كما بلونا اصحاب
الجنه اذ اقسموا ليصرمنها
مصبحين ولا
يستثنون فطاف عليها
طائف من ربك وهم
نائم
فاصبحت
كالصريم فتنادوا
مصبحين ان اغدوا على حر على حرثكم ان كنتم
صارمين
فانطلقوا وهم يتخافتون
الا
يدخلنها اليوم عليكم
مسكين وغدوا على حر
قادرين فلما راوها قالوا انا
لضالون بل نحن
محرومون قال اوسطهم الم اقل لكم لولا
تسبحون قالوا سبحان ربنا انا كنا ظالمين
فاقبل بعضهم على بعض
يتلاومون قالوا يا ويلنا انا كنا
طاغين عسى ربنا ان يبدلنا خيرا منها انا
الى ربنا
راغبون كذلك
العذاب عذاب الاخره اكبر لو كانوا
يعلمون ان
للمتقين عند ربهم
جنات
نعيم
افنجعل المسلمين كالمجرمين
ما لكم كيف
تحكمون ام لكم
كتاب فيه
تدرسون
ان لكم لما
تخيرون ان لكم فيه لما
تخيرون ام لكم ايمان علينا بالغه الى يوم
القيامه
ان لكم لما
تحكمون سلهم ايم بذلك
زعيم ام لهم
شركاء فلياتوا
بشركائهم ان كانوا
صادقين يوم يكشف عن ساق ويدعون الى السجود
فلا
يستطيعون خاشعه ابصارهم ترهقهم
ذله وقد كانوا يدعون الى السجود وهم
سالمون
فذرني ومن يكذب بهذا
الحديث سنستدرجهم من حيث لا
يعلمون واملي لهم ان كيدي
متين ام تسالهم اجرا فهم من مغرم
مثقلون ام
عندهم الغ فهم
يكتبون فاصبر لحكم ربك ولا تكن كصاحب
الحوت ولا تكن كصاحب الحوت اذ نادى وهو
مكظوم لولا ان تداركه
نعمه من ربه لنبذ بالعرا لنبذ في
العراء وهو
مذموم فاجتباه ربه فجعله من
الصالحين وان يكادوا الذين كفروا ليزلقونك
بابصارهم لما سمعوا
الذكر وان يكادوا الذين كفروا ليزلقونك
بابصارهم لما سمعوا الذكر وي قولون انه
لمجنون وان يكاد الذين كفروا ليزلقونك
بابصارهم لما سمعوا الذكر ويقولون انه
لمجنون وما هو الا ذكر
للعالمين الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعب واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
الحاقه ما الح
حاقه وما ادراك ما
الحاقه كذبت كذبت كذبت
ثمود كذب الثمود
وعاد
بالقارعه فاما ثمود فاهلكوا
بالطاغيه واما
عاد فاهلكوا بريح صرصر
عاتيه سخرها عليهم سبع ليال وثمانيه ايام
حسوما فترى القوم فيها صرعا كانهم اعجاز
نخل
خاويه فهل ترى لهم من باقيه
وجاء فرعون ومن قبل
والمؤتفكات
بالخاطئه فعصوا رسول ربهم فاخذهم اخذه
الرابيه
انا لما طغى
الماء حملناكم في
الجاريه لنجعلها لكم
تذكره وتعيها اذن
واعيه فاذا نفخ في الص
نفخه
واحده وحملت الارض والجبال فدكتا دكه
واحده
فيومئذ وقعت
الواقعه
وانشقت
السماء فهي
يومئذ
واهيه والملك على
ارجائها
ويحمل عرش ربك فوقهم
يومئذ
ثمانيه
يومئذ تعرضون لا تخفى منكم خافيه
فاما من اوتي كتابه بيمينه
فيقول فيقول
هاؤم اقراوا كتاب
اني
ظننت اني ملاق
حسابيه فهو في عيشه
راضيه في
جنه عاليه
قطوفها
دانيه كلوا واشربوا
هنيئا بما اسلفتم في الايام
الخاليه واما من اوت
كتابه بشماله
فيقول فيقول يا ليتني لم اوت
كتابيه ولم ادر ما
حسابيه يا ليتها كانت
القاضيه ما اغنى عني ماليه هلك
عني
سلطانيه خذوه
فقلو
ثم الجحيم
صلوه ثم في
سلسله ذرعها سبعون
ذراعا فاسلكوه
انه كان لا يؤمن بالله
العظيم ولا يحض على طعام
المسكين فليس له اليوم هاهنا
حميم ولا طعام الا من
غسلين لا
ياكله الا
الخاطئون فلا اقسم بما تبصرون وما لا
تبصرون
انه لقول
رسول
كريم وما هو بقول شاعر
قليلا ما
تؤمنون ولا بقول
كاهن
قليلا ما
تذكرون
تنزيل من رب
العالمين ولو تقول علينا بعض الاقاويل
لاخذنا منه باليمين ثم لقطعنا منه
الوتين فما
منكم من احد عنه
حاجزين
وانا لنعلم ان منكم
مكذبين فما منكم من احد عنه
حاجزين وان انه لتذكره
للمتقين وانا لنعلم ان منكم
مكذبين
وانه لحسره على
الكافرين
وانه لحق اليقين فسبح باسم ربك العظيم
الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
الله اكبر بسبحان
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين سال
سائل
بعذاب واقع
للكافرين ليس له دافع من الله ذي
المعارج تعرج
الملائكه والروح اليه في يوم كان مقداره 5
الف سنه فاصبر صبرا جميلا انهم يرونه
بعيدا ونراه
قريبا يوم تكون
السماء كالمهل وتكون الجبال كالعهن ولا
يسال حميم حميما
يبصرونهم يود المجرم لو يفتدي من عذاب
يومئذ
ببنيه
وصاحبته
واخيه
وفصيلته التي
تؤويه ومن في الارض
جميعا ثم
ينجيه كلا
انها لظى زاعه للشوى تدعو من ادبر وتولى
وجمع
فاوعى
ان
الانسان خلق
هلوعا اذا مسه الشر جزوعا واذا مسه الخير
منوعا الا
المصلين الذين هم على صلاتهم
دا
ئون والذين في اموالهم حق
معلوم
للسائل
والمحروم والذين يصدقون بيوم الدين والذين
هم من عذاب ربهم
مشفقون ان عذاب ربهم غير مامون
والذين هم لفروجهم
حافظون الا على ازواجهم او ما ملكت
ايمانهم فانهم غير
ملومين فمن ابتغى وراء ذلك
فاولئك هم العادون والذين هم والذين هم
على والذين هم
والذين هم
لاانهم وعهدهم راعون والذين هم
بشهاداتهم
قائمون والذين هم على صلاتهم
يحافظون
اولئك في
جنات
مكرمون فما للذين كفروا قبلك مهطعين
عن اليمين وعن الشمال عزين ايطمع كل امرئ
منهم ان يدخل جنه نعيم كلا انا
خلقناهم مما
يعلمون فلا اقسم برب المشارق والمغارب على
انا
لقادرون فلا اقسم برب المشارق والمغارب
لقادرون على ان نبدل خيرا منهم وما نحن
بمسبوقين فذرهم يخوضوا ويلعبوا حتى يلاقوا
يومهم الذي فيه يوعد يومهم الذي
يوعدون يوم يخرجون من الاجداث سراعا
كانهم الى نصب يوفضون
خاشعه ابصارهم ترهقهم
ذله ذلك اليوم الذي كانوا
يوعدون الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحم الحمد
لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين انا ارسلنا نوحا الى قومه ان انذر
قومك ان انذر قومك من قبل ان ياتيهم عذاب
اليم قال يا قوم اني لكم نذير مبين ان
اعبدوا الله واتقوه
واطيعون يغفر لكم من ذنوبكم
ويؤخركم الى اجل
مسمى ان اجل الله اذا
جاء لا يؤ خر لو كنتم
تعلمون قال رب اني دعوت قومي ليلا
ونهارا فلم يزدهم
دعائي الا
فرارا واني كلما دعوتهم لتغفر لهم
جعلوا جعلوا اصابعهم في اذانهم واستغشوا
ثيابهم واصروا واستكبروا
استكبارا ثم اني دعوتهم
جهارا ثم اني اعلنت لهم واسررت لهم
اسرارا فقلت استغفروا ربكم
انه كان
غفارا يرسل
السماء
عليكم
مدرارا
ويمددكم
باموال
وبنين ويجعل لكم
جنات ويجعل لكم
انهارا ما لكم لا ترجون لله وقارا وقد
خلقكم
اطوارا الم تروا كيف خلق الله سبع
سماوات
طباقا وجعل القمر
فيه
نورا وجعل الشمس
سراجا والله
انبتكم من الارض
نباتا ثم يعيدكم فيها ويخرجكم
اخراجا والله جعل لكم الارض
بساطا لتسلكوا منها
سبلا
فجاجا قال نوح رب انهم عصوني واتبعوا من
لم يزده ماله
وولده الا
خسارا ومكروا مكرا
كبارا وقالوا لا تذرن الهتكم
ولا تذرن
ودا ولا
سواعا ولا يغوث ويعوق
ونسرا وقد اضلوا
كثيرا فلا تزد الظالمين الا
ضلالا مما
خطيئاتهم اغرقوا فادخلوا نارا فلم يجدوا
لهم من دون الله
انصارا وقال نوح رب لا تذر على الارض من
الكافرين
ديارا
انك ان تذرهم يضلوا عبادك ولا يلدوا الا
كافرا ولا يلدوا الا
فاجرا
كفارا
رب اغفر لي
ولوالدي ولمن دخل بيتي
مؤمنا ولمن دخل بيتي
مؤمنا
وللمؤمنين والمؤمنات
ولا تزد
الظالمين الا
تبارا الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
صلاه
الش
استقيم الله الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين لم يكن الذين كفروا من اهل الكتاب
والمشركين
منفكين حتى تاتيهم
البينه رسول من الله يتلو صحفا
مطهره فيها كتب
قيمه وما تفرق الذين اوتوا الكتاب الا من
بعد ما
جاءتهم
البينه وما امروا الا ليعبدوا الله مخلصين
له الدين
حنفاء ويقيموا الصلاه ويؤت
الزكاه وذلك دين
القيمه ان ان الذين كفروا من اهل الكتاب
والمشركين في نار جهنم خالدين فيها
اولئك هم شر
البريه ان الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
اولئك هم خير
البريه
جزاؤهم عند ربهم جنات عد
تجري من تحتها
الانهار خالدين فيها ابدا رضي الله عنهم
ورضوا عنه ذلك لمن خشي
ربه الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضال
امين اذا زلزلت الارض
زلزالها واخرجت الارض
اثقالها وقال الانسان
ماالها
يومئذ تحدث
اخبارها بان ربك اوحى لها يومئذ يصدر النا
اشتاتا ليروا
اعمالهم فمن يعمل مثقال ذره خيرا يره ومن
يعمل مثقال ذره
شرا يره الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستق
مستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قل هو الله احد الله الصمد لم يلد
ولم يولد ولم يكن له كفوا احد الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده ربنا لك الحمد حمدا كثيرا طيبا
مباركا فيه اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على سيدنا
محمد اللهم اهدنا في من هديت وعافنا في من
عافيت وتولنا في من توليت وبارك لنا في ما
اعطيت وقنا شر ما قضيت اللهم انك عفو تحب
العفو فاعف عنا اللهم انك عفو تحب العفو
فاعف عنا اللهم انك عفو تحب العفو فاعف
عنا اللهم انا نسالك العفو والعافيه في
الدنيا والاخره اللهم عافنا في اسماعنا
وعافنا في ابصارنا وعا فنا واعف عنا وعلى
طاعتك اعنا ومن رحمتك لا تحرمنا ربنا لا
تجعلنا فتنه للقوم الظالمين ونجنا برحمتك
من القوم
الكافرين ربنا افرغ علينا صبرا وثبت
اقدامنا وانصرنا على القوم
الكافرين اللهم حبب الينا الايمان وزينه
في قلوبنا وكره الينا الكفر والفسوق
والعصيان واجعلنا من
الراشدين ربنا اتمم لنا نورنا واغفر لنا
انك على كل شيء قدير اللهم اغفر لنا
ولابائنا و اهاتنا ولاصحاب الحقوق علينا
واغفر للمؤمنين والمؤمنات والمسلمين
والمسلمات احياء
وامواتا اللهم بلغنا ليله قدر واكتب لنا
ثوابها واجعلنا من
عتقائك من النار ومن
المقبولين
لا اله الا انت سبحانك انا كنا من
الظالمين اللهم من على اخواننا المستضعفين
في السودان وغزه وغيرهما بالنصر والتمكين
كل لهم عونا ونصيرا وسندا اللهم امنه الله
اللهم اطعمهم من جوع وامنهم من خوف اللهم
ثبت اقدامهم واربط على قلوبهم وانزل
السكينه عليهم واهلك اعداءهم وانتقم من
ظالميهم اللهم ارغم انوف
المتكبرين اللهم اهلك المستكبرين اللهم
اضرب الظالمين بالظالمين واخرج المسلمين
من بينهم سالمين ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه
وفي الاخره حسنه وقنا عذاب النار صلى الله
وسلم وبارك على سيدنا محمد وعلى اله
واصحابه اجمعين الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله اكر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه